ciao ragazzi bentornati 1 video su
questo canale un video che volevo fare
da un sacco da almeno sei ore visto che
prima di allora io nemmeno idea che se
stessa possibilità di fare una roba
simile è quello che faremo oggi è un
quiz tra due mie carissime amiche che si
sfideranno in quella che è la conoscenza
del sottoscritto la conoscenza che
sicuramente voi avrete maggiore perché i
miei amici di buzz anzano nulla di me e
che alla fine riporterà a ottenere il
titolo ambitissimo migliore amica il
titolo di migliore amica porta con sé un
regalo personalizzato che desiderate ne
ho una per te è una mente misto è una
ricezione un basta ho pensato di
prendervi per il portafoglio ha capito
dove stimolarmi almeno corale esistono
tanti altri modi e tranquilla
avrete ognuna di cui una lavagnetta che
caso in cui qualcuno sbagli ma ben nome
kakà tercal abbiamo subito la prima
domanda in che giorno sono nato già
vinto matera in dubbio tra 23 e 27 figli
annullate quindi punte qual è il mio
colore preferito tra loro vi abbia la
diano verde e il fucsia odio il viola
infatti il mio correndo il rito era
molto simile tuoi ex capelli tagliare
akita ho perso la verginità 19 perché 20
21 normale e 21 sono sicura che sia 21
posso dire io ho visto che ci abbiamo
fatto un video di recente benini che
bravissime qual è il mio fratello
preferito tirate dipende dall'occasione
era questa la risposta cosa mi fa più
paura
cosa mi mette molta ansia
questo non perdere la tua amica
valentina è solo di queste è la morte
del mio cane ma i miei fratelli più
grande capitano gianluigi magari è
sicuro sicuro enrico quanti anni ho
vissuto in sicilia quando ero piccolo
non ne sono sicura 10 9 lo sapevo con
graziani dico solo che ieri ha detto
dammi impedendo a come si chiamava la
mia fidanzatina delle elementari
non lo so valeria in via giuliana lo
sapevo qual è il mio sogno più grande di
scrivere un nuovo libro quando mi scade
il contratto di affitto di questa casa
ma ci ha accompagnato a fare oggi sono
io di gavi partendo in 3d umani le carte
che devo fare i notai come naturalmente
come ho mai fatto sesso una donna ho mai
baciato una donna si è la soluzione che
graziano di che colore ha gli occhi neo
mamma guarda che ti do una sedia redi
trovate su quanto sta dicendo gialli per
l'italia
marroni ma mano ogni coltura di ieri
avendo di come le sue gambe
io sono una persona che potrebbe fare
sesso al primo appuntamento si segue
molto volta qual è il viaggio che vorrei
fare più di ogni altra cosa
giappone siamo sarebbe mittel inizi che
papà david oltre al pianoforte flauto
dolce che altro strumento strin ten il
posto più strano in cui l'ho fatto lo
sapevo che me lo chiede v metti che non
urla della vita di tutta la capitale ha
già andare un rima no nessuno dei due
c'è la di ryanair sulle scale androne
davanti all'ascensore di un albergo non
si fa ma la passione dell'uomo [ __ ]
come si chiamava il mio personaggio su
freaks che potevi aveva mai banali e
tremendo veramente di varese con te qual
è il titolo del primo video che ho
postato su internet tra l'altro grande
capolavoro grande cult è andato però
tutti a vedere il mio primo vero svetta
prego non parlo la smetti annosa 19 di
tempo questo sciacca buon natale c'era
più vicine graziella natalizia ma non è
quello che non ho mai fatto tre non vi è
infatti 19 fatto non me l'hai disastro
non sono sbagliato tutti e due andiamo
avanti
una volta ma non ce l'hai mai detto ve
lo dico adesso sa che lou reed a chi
tatuaggio vorrei farmi realta nei due
quindi tutti e due
allora sei qui sotto lo scroto oppure io
così perché mi viene prima però avete
scritto nessuno quale sport pratichiamo
da piccolo ultimata la bolla vuoto primo
punto per graziata
fai clic nuotatore per quanti anni e
durata delle relazioni più lunghe dire
anche cioè le cagate d'amore qual è il
film che mi ha fatto più piangere in
assoluto questo è il secondo set ed
altri mi ha fatto piangere moltissimo il
mio film preferito della disney per
allegamenti quindi ritornate a 0.2
qual è la cosa più stupida che io abbia
fatto da ubriaco ha sempre male appare
divide tra un bicchiere di plastica di
birra davanti a tutti e non per me il
vostro a sedere o al quale superpoteri
vorrei avere ma nel frattempo chi mi
conosce di più enrico è anche questa tu
sai certo in che le navi tanto no la
cura io vorrei curare e io qualcuno
imbecille di che colore era il mio
motorino rosso carta da zucchero ceo
dove ho fatto il mio primo piercing
questo qua aspetta che io ho detto
romani del milan catania che pippa chi
mi ha eliminato a pechino express non è
male di melania
bravissima ma chi l'avrebbe salita
quando voi il numero delle persone più o
meno con quel fatto sesso a 21 anni nota
prima che non l'hanno fatto
glen grant ha più di 30 sicuramente sì
diciamo che ho perso in quel conto ma
rimaniamo comunque si su una trentina
imporante mentre cifre prima rete in a
barre al tetto vero come si chiamava mio
nonno del mis pagliativo e senza
emozioni degli styles una delle persone
più importanti della mia vita
gino corazzina 1 milione si chiama gino
una mio nonno colore per lavoro si
chiama salvatore verrà appunto
qual è il nome del primo personaggio che
io ho mai interpretato in un l'urp
questo assolutamente non è come se
soddisfatte sicura di te qual è il
codice di sblocco del mio telefono non
lo fate rete è giusto giusto mi hanno
mai spezzato il cuore
il primo mobile che ho comprato in
questa casa di milano che mi son
frequentato se riuscite a metterci anche
il nome prendete un punto in più
classico si deve analizzare abbiamo mai
troppo facili le file su cosa ho fatto
la tesina liceo ma purtroppo facile il
fortunato è saperlo tra il giappone
alistair non era tipo un'interpretazione
teatrale si sul pessimismo cosmico
posizione preferita ha letto un punto
per metterla a quanti hanno portato da
parecchio tre anni non l'hai portato a
12 anni
quello che questo sorriso il colore è
stata la mia prima parrucca leon rossa
nera qual è la prima macchina che io ho
guidato la panna
guidata da però ci sta l'errore non
venire volevi fare quel terrore è cosa
mi ha scritto imparare l'inglese e
giochi online quello che mi ha spinto ad
andare su quel gioco sul pc è stato
harry potter questo momento che ha
scritto in inglese come girato un po
meno pubblicano pubblico no no sbagliato
non piccoli non si vede la faccia
scherzi bagno o doccia magnum pipì in
piedi o seduto non è sicura i geni
seduto naga tutta la vita per bulino
dolce o salato a segno zodiacale
sagittario ascendente leone a cretina se
aver finito l'ascendente brava volevo
fare almeno per una volta iscritto lato
6 ma anche non è stata una figura amori
di sogni o carriera di sogni fanno
l'amore primo animale domestico unito
no prospero per la tartaruga ho mai
indossato intimo da donna si no non è
per venire o intimo da donna per i tre
tesi però sono sicuro che lavoro volevo
fare da grande quando ero piccolo il
dottore è un bomber come fatto una rissa
anticipato di una cena dico no ma non è
vero che in chiesa a campano farò una
colluttazione a uno che faceva il
bulletto gli e lesionate milo suonate
cioè magari possa avere avuto una
reazione siamo gli ultimi due re il mio
cibo preferito che scendessero
bravissime ultimissima domanda chi
preferisco tra cui due ragazzi la botta
che è la vera vincitrice di questo gioco
è molto mia migliore amica
grazie comunque vinto tu hai fatto un
più 1
anche la sera pensano di vincere più
facilmente ci sono alcune domande troppo
complesse mi aspettavo cosa invece un po
più recenti ma no è una cosa facile
vabbè che ha vinto nessuna delle due
piccole botta che l'avrebbe immaginato
il regalo solo perché la fetta sentito a
casa grazie alle mie ragazze
questa si chiama [ __ ]
no